le 17 octobre il y avait une
massacre d'ailleurs la scène chalier des
corps d'algériens plusieurs semaines
après le 17 octobre c'est le joueur
qu'on arrive à terme
le ballon jusqu'à présent on n'a jamais
sur le nombre de morts qu'il ya eu
14hoo
ancien responsable de la fédération de
france du fln dans l'est de la france
je m'appelle mahfoud réside à amiens
somme sur neuer qui m'appelle jamais
naaman g 87 ans j'ai participé sept top
6 à terre
[Musique]
m
c'était bien
expliquer qu'on ne devait porter rien
sur nous pas même une épingle à nourrice
parce qu'on avait bien précisé que cette
marche très pacifique il y avait des
hommes à la sortie qu'ils arrêtent et
tous les hommes qui sortaient de minots
vie pour vérifier qu'ils aient pas même
un cas ni sur les algériens n'avaient
pas d'autre choix que de dénoncer ce
couvre-feu et de manifester lorsqu'on
arrive sur paris on commence à voir la
police un peu partout avec des matches
et un seul coup les crs ont tiré et moi
je vois encore les hommes du premier run
tomber des algériens allongés par terre
dans
106 une journée d'horreur d'horreur j'en
ai vu qui ont été jetés dans la seine et
j'en ai vu qu essayer de s'accrocher des
buissons qui est elle au bord de la
seine pour essayer de se trouver
tout ça je n'ai vu c'est pas quelque
chose on raconte ou ou qu'on imagine
[Musique]
on
quand on est revenu le soir on s'est
aperçu qu'elle beaucoup de factures
disparu n'a pas de nouvelles
moi j'ai quand même une chance
qui peut-être grâce à ça je suis
aujourd'hui pour vous raconter tout ça
c'est qu'il ya une dame française qui a
ouvert un portail qui m'a attrapé par le
bras et qui m'a fait rentrer chez elle
[Musique]
n'avez pas quand le bilan n'a pas été
établie immédiatement mais le savions
que les algériens qui ont manifesté
n'étaient pas nombreux ici la plupart
habitent ensemble dans des
dégarni dans des comme le bidonville de
long terme donc ils ont commencé à
compter le monde partage julienne qui ne
sont pas revenus de la manifestation
[Musique]
au petit matin on a vu tous ces hommes
arrivés complètement éclatée restera en
à oignies et blessés voir comme on
pouvait 1 et on n'a fait que ça pendant
des jours le bidonville était devenu un
hôpital de campagne
[Musique]
dans la semaine on a eu droit à une
rafle terrible en hôtel quand on arrive
dans le camp enfin demain celle de
cartouches et il ya deux fils de bonus
c'est notre milieu est pas venu couper
chacun des crachats
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose dont tu sais ne
fallait pas parler s'était pas une
guerre
faut se rappeler
c'était les événements à bûcher pays
[Musique]
souvent on dit qu il ya eu
répression nous il ya un monde entre
répression qui peut être très importante
pas importante 1 tandis que massacre
c'est tout à fait autre chose
[Musique]
on a toujours voulu que ce soit revenu
on espère que cette année notre
président monsieur mac on va voir
reconnaître que les algériens et les
algériennes ont été massacrés en plein
paris